British beauty blog essential.com
although it's spelled es si en tu l comm
polled its readers to find out what men
and women view as the perfect facial
features to construct the perfect woman
so first let's take a look at the
perfect woman
according to men all right so we can all
look at this and you can see which
famous actresses of course they've
picked for this this woman doesn't look
to me like any one that I would want to
hang out with she looks a little too
Kardashian II for me and I don't I don't
know that I would want to spend any time
with her but let's look at the perfect
woman
according to women right now oh my god
yeah normal well this is what women say
a woman should look like and then we
wonder why women have all these issues
and you can see which actresses they've
picked both men and women picked the
Megan Fox chin interestingly enough yeah
and and the Mila Kunis eyes so there you
go alright this we see this kind of
stuff all the time oh and I want to show
you one other thing so Jennifer Lawrence
was on the cover of flare magazine she's
beautiful she's in her early 20s she's
got everything going on for but of
course yeah they photoshopped her so
let's look at the cover first so that's
the cover on the left and that's just
the image of her on the right now they
actually don't look that different right
but if you look a little closer you can
see things like her fingers are actually
a little bit longer on the Photoshop
version they've done some things with
her cheekbones and her eyes we've got a
gift or as the kids say a Jif of it
let's look at that
so you can see her her boobs are a
little sloppy Photoshop because in order
to bring in her waist you'll notice
they've got her arm bending backwards
they just in the middle of the picture
the point there is that they're taking
women that are already beautiful and
then they do that I mean lengthening of
the fingers my fingers are acceptable I
mean this is what leads to do you like
thank you I was having trouble focusing
I think this is exactly what leads to
the insecurities that women face today I
think men also have significant
insecurities you know when it comes to
the body image and everything but for
women it's like your lips gotta be full
and you got to have a small nose and
long hair and big boobs small ways and
it's this constant messaging that we get
and it's really difficult you know I
made a quote once on the show that
people really liked and it's true
there's nothing in the world that's more
expensive than insecurity right because
insecurities force you to go out there
and spend money whether it's you know
anti-wrinkle cream or going out there
and getting your breasts enlarged it's
so expensive to deal with all of that
stuff and I would love to preach and say
you know accept yourself for who you are
but I would be extremely hypocritical
you know I had my insecurities I went
out there and I dealt with my
insecurities I put makeup on for the
show every day and it's really hard not
to cave into that pressure yeah I think
no I think it's bad for the psyche of a
culture I don't think it is just may
adjust female or just male
there's so little room for for
difference in our world now even as we
are expanding the the rights of gays as
we were expanding the rights of the
LGBTQ community at the same time we're
saying this is what beauty is supposed
to look like and not only do we need to
alter photos of beautiful people to make
them more what we imagine beauty should
be but now we're doing studies as to how
we might combine people to find the
ideal beauty and men who find other
things attractive are ashamed of it
right so you're a guy who likes a girl
with slightly bigger nose let's say then
my god what a freak yeah if there's any
any particular thing that appeals to you
that is not absolutely the norm you feel
like you're ashamed and you need to
have been scientific studies into beauty
and what people in general find
attractive and so you can focus on
symmetry and and you know certain things
like that and it has to do with our
biological urges and our you know our
needs to reproduce you know certain
facial features and certain body
proportions usually mean that a woman is
more fertile is better for a
reproduction yada yada but I do agree
with you I mean it it's really scary to
know that we do live in a society where
everyone is pressured to look the same
and I think it's kind of up to us to
kind of push back against that and do
things that we're comfortable with and
embrace our bodies and embrace the way
we look and again I'm being hypocritical
because I haven't embraced the way I
look and I put on makeup every single
day and I do my thing but is that
hypocrisy just is trying to look your
best on a day to day basis yeah let's
keep it real beauty is freakin power
okay especially for people that are in
front of a camera and I'm not gonna sit
here and pretend that my looks don't
play a role in my success obviously if
I'm up against another woman and she's
less attractive than me I'm probably
gonna get that job over her I mean let's
say we had the exact same qualifications
that's what the reality is and at the
same time Jennifer Grey was way more
appealing before she had her nose
genericized so she's a great example of
this so she was in Dirty Dancing of
course and she had her look well you
know she had a bigger nose and it wasn't
just that her she had just a quirky sort
of look and then she ended up getting
all the plastic surgery she did win
Dancing with the Stars but she hasn't
done anything since then and I think she
looked much better back then is it fair
to blame it all on her plastic surgery
though people always like to blame it on
her nose job I wasn't saying anyone how
much work she got I'm just saying I
found her way more appealing yeah as the
human being that she was then as the
genericized version of herself that she
became I I think in addition to all of
the the genetic and and evolutionary
issues the search for symmetry and so on
at least four men and I don't know what
the distinction is gender-wise there's a
great deal of imprinting that goes on
early childhood and moments that cause
these permanent grooves in the brain
that lead to fetishism and deviation
that I do not think as being deviant but
rather as being the norm the the vast
spectrum of norm and I think it is time
that both men and women began to embrace
the idea that some people really like a
huge freakin mole in the middle of the
nose and some people are into amputees
and some guys would go nuts for a woman
with a hunchback you know I think every
chance I get and I think and I think
humanity needs to just start embracing
the great beauty of all of it
yeah and that picture of the Pope
hugging the guy with the growths all
over his head it didn't freak people out
because the Pope was doing something
good it freaked people out because we're
not supposed to embrace the unusual yeah
final thought on this so obviously a lot
of this has to do with just the
messaging that we're getting constantly
isn't there something a little weird
about that it all comes from actors so
actors are getting Botox and they're
getting all this chin implants up where
they can no longer move their faces the
very tool that they're supposed to use
for their craft and their art and then
all these it that something about how
the insecurities that these people that
want to be seen all the time are
constantly changing themselves and that
that their insecurities is them being
pushed on to all of us because I don't
think that the average person suffers
from that level of insecurity that these
that people that are in front of the
camera and obviously we're in front of
the camera right this second but that
there's something sort of different
about that level of insecurity and
wanting to be liked that then it's been
pushed on regular people constantly yes
that make any sense I did make sense
look I've met a number of people in Los
Angeles that are struggling actors
they're the most vain people on the
planet and it's not and it's because
that's the nature of what they do
you have to look like this alien
supermodel just in order to get cast in
certain roles I mean if you look at all
the major celebrities they're all
perfect looking and if they're not
perfect looking there's someone who's
photoshopping them as they walk around
and do you know and they're doing
whatever they're doing but I mean that's
just the nature of the beast that's what
the market responds to yeah okay so if
the markets gonna respond to that then
they're gonna continue doing it I just
one example is Gabourey Sidibe I'm sorry
if I'm mispronouncing her name but she
was in that movie precious right which
her performance was spectacular in that
movie it was one of the best movies I've
ever seen but she got criticized
significantly for her weight she was
named as you know Person of the Year or
something like that in one of these
magazines and people were outraged by it
because they thought oh she's fat she's
you know supporting an unhealthy image
and this and that you're gonna get
criticized either way you're either too
beautiful or you're too ugly so the way
you do you deal with it is to just tune
them out and live your life